[Música]
cientos de ciudadanos peruanos llegaron
a la capital para sumarse a la
denominada toma de Lima los
manifestantes piden la liberación del
expresidente Pedro Castillo la renuncia
de la presidenta Dina boluarte y
elecciones en 2023 entre otras demandas
sigue escalando la tensión diplomática
entre Colombia y Guatemala el presidente
colombiano Gustavo Petro desde davos
Suiza calificó la investigación por
parte de Guatemala contra suministro de
defensa como una acción corrupta
previamente ambos países convocaron a
consultas a sus representantes
diplomáticos
se cumplieron ocho años del
fallecimiento de Alberto nisma en el
fiscal argentino hallado muerto en su
baño la noche antes ha oficializar sus
acusaciones contra Cristina Fernández
por un presunto encubrimiento a los
autores del atentado a la mutual judía
Argentina en 1994 mientras su familia
denuncia que la investigación del caso
no avanza
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos en Perú allí
centenares de personas procedentes de
diferentes regiones del país se reúnen
en Lima como parte de una gran
movilización para pedir la renuncia de
la presidenta Dina boluarte el cierre
del Congreso y convocar a una asamblea
Constituyente tras más de un mes de
manifestaciones los enfrentamientos
entre las fuerzas de seguridad y los
manifestantes han dejado unos 50 muertos
el informe es de lluís Muñoz por mi
patria la vida Lima lista para la gran
manifestación nacional autobuses de todo
Perú han llegado a la capital
procedentes incluso de juliaca donde
murieron 19 personas en la jornada más
Sangrienta de las protestas
[Música]
así lucen los albergues con Campesinos
de todo el país en protesta contra el
gobierno de Dina boluarte más de 30
horas de viaje Vamos a organizarnos ya
para el recorrido que vamos a realizar
con una movilización pacífica como he
indicado una protesta transversal donde
también participan estudiantes Esta es
la Universidad Nacional mayor de San
Marcos la más antigua de Sudamérica como
estudiantes no estamos cerrando el
diálogo en ningún momento y más bien
empezamos a que la rectora pueda acceder
a este diálogo y que se puede dar una
colación de manera democrática que no se
siga reprimiendo asesinando más a
nuestro pueblo no el gobierno de Dina
boluarte insiste en que quieren avanzar
en el diálogo y deja en manos del
Ministerio Público Las investigaciones
el ministro de finanzas Álex Contreras
dijo que las protestas se están
moderando las pretensiones de algunos
grupos que querían por ejemplo la
renuncia el cierre del Congreso la
asamblea Constituyente se están se está
moderando
pero para el analista Joan Lara la
situación responde a cuestiones
estructurales hay un proceso continuo de
tensiones no resueltas hay un elemento
muy fuerte de desigualdad económica que
se traduce en términos también
desigualdad social política cultural de
todo tipo las protestas se extienden
desde el ocho de diciembre tras el
intento de disolver el congreso del
expresidente Pedro Castillo que terminó
siendo detenido acusado de darse un
autogolpe de estado de vacancia y mi
contra siguen escalando las tensiones
diplomáticas entre Colombia y Guatemala
que tienen en el centro de la polémica
una denuncia contra el actual ministro
de defensa colombiano Iván Velásquez
desde el foro económico mundial de davos
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
exigió respeto para él como jefe de
estado y para Iván Velázquez como
ministro calificó la investigación
contra su funcionario como una acción
corrupta a este intercambio de
comentarios precede el llamado a
consultas de sus respectivas
trabajadoras como respuesta al anuncio
de Guatemala de procesar a Velázquez a
quien acusan de supuestamente haber
cometido actos ilegales en el caso de
que cuando ejerció como jefe de la
comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en Guatemala la sijic entre
2013 y 2017 un organismo creado con
auspicio de la ONU para ayudar a
investigar la participación de
funcionarios en crímenes y que entre
otros señaló de defraudación al
expresidente Otto Pérez Molina es que
echemos al mandatario colombiano
nuestro ministro de defensa se respeta y
el presidente se respeta
nosotros no vamos a rodear la soberanía
nacional ante una acción corrupta
provenga de quien provenga y se saben ya
los nombres exactos etcétera lo que
estar es vengándose de una acción que
iba contra la impunidad tomada por
Naciones Unidas no por el gobierno de
Colombia pero con un ciudadano
colombiano al frente que merece todo el
respeto por su accionar y el presidente
de Brasil Luis Ignacio de Lula da Silva
volvió a señalar al expresidente
bolsonaro por instigar los hechos de
violencia del 8 de enero
no sé si el expresidente lo ordenó Pero
lo que sí sé es que es culpable porque
pasó cuatro años instigando el odio
entre la gente mintiendo a la sociedad
brasileña
instigando a que la gente tenga que
estar Armada para garantizar la
democracia
se cumplieron ocho años del
fallecimiento de Alberto nisman en el
fiscal argentino que fue hallado muerto
en su baño con un disparo en la cabeza
esto la noche antes a la que debía
oficializar sus acusaciones contra
Cristina Fernández por un presunto
encubrimiento a los autores del a la
mutual judía Argentina en 1994 un caso
emblemático que profundizó las
diferencias políticas en el país Ramiro
cuevar verena con los detalles
el 18 de enero de 2015 murió Alberto
nisman el fiscal argentino que había
denunciado un presunto encubrimiento del
gobierno de Cristina Fernández a los
autores del atentado de la asociación
mutual israelita Argentina de 1994 el
acto terrorista más grande de la
historia del país sudamericano al día
siguiente nisman debía revalidar sus
acusaciones pero fue encontrado muerto
con un disparo en la cabeza en el baño
de su departamento en el barrio Porteño
de Puerto Madero
una escena poco clara que profundizó
irreversiblemente la grieta política
Argentina y dio lugar a versiones
cruzadas de un lado refieren a un
suicidio y del otro a un asesinato
Yo espero que se esclarezca que que
vayan presas los culpables quedaron dos
hijas sin padre y además para el país
entero es un y el mundo entero es un mal
ejemplo que un fiscal de la nación este
muerto por y que no haya ningún
esclarecimiento Cuál es la idea entonces
la primera demostrar a partir
No ya de los planteos jurídicos que
vamos a hacer posteriormente
sino de la más simple lógica del
disparate
judicial
institucional y político que es esta
acusación actualmente el expediente
sobre su fallecimiento está estancado a
cargo del fiscal Eduardo tallano y el
juez Julián arcolini ambos afines a la
derecha nacional no se ha podido
comprobar que se trate un intento de
asesinato tal como insistió la esposa de
nisman la jueza Sandra Arroyo Salgado
Por ahora sólo están procesados Diego
lagomarcino asesor informático de nisman
y dueño del arma implicada y los cuatro
custodios encargados de la seguridad del
fiscal uno de los megaproyectos mineros
en Chile quedó suspendido por decisión
de un comité de ministros los
funcionarios consideraron que la
explotación de hierro y cobre y el
puerto que pretendía Construir la
compañía antes Iron ponían en riesgo la
biodiversidad de la zona Aunque la
decisión será apelada el informe es de
María Clara calle
se suspende el proyecto minero Dominga
en Chile por lo menos por ahora la
decisión la tomó un comité conformado
por seis ministros del gabinete después
de que en mayo de 2022 la Corte Suprema
les enviara una batalla jurídica que
comenzó en 2017 de forma unánime este
comité de ministro resolvió acoger las
doce reclamaciones y por lo tanto
queda con una evaluación de favorable el
proyecto minero portuario Dominga la
compañía andes Iron recurrirá la
decisión su proyecto de 2.500 millones
de dólares es para explotar hierro y
cobre durante 22 años pero los
ambientalistas se oponen porque esta es
una de las zonas marinas más biodiversas
del planeta la mina el tofu y el puerto
de totoralillo Norte serían en el centro
del país sobre el Pacífico a 16
kilómetros de la comuna la higuera y
también muy cerca de la reserva nacional
pingüino de Humboldt donde se encuentra
el 80% ciento de esta especie en peligro
que la corriente que es la que tenemos
en Chile va de Sur a Norte Entonces al
norte de estos proyectos está la reserva
más antigua de chile que es donde
habitan
de Humboldt pero también
las ballenas Entonces por ejemplo un
derrame de hidrocarburo eso acabaría
irreversiblemente con eso ecosistema
Lizbeth vandermare también le explicó a
France 24 que ellos impulsan que la zona
se ha declarada como área Marina
protegida pues Dominga no es el único
proyecto una termoeléctrica que se llama
barrancones esa fue el primer proyecto
que se baja la zona por su importancia
biológica después vinieron dos
termoeléctricas más ahora un megapuerto
y hay otro megapuerto que se llama cap
que también está situada en la zona
entonces este tiene un gran interés y
creemos que estos intereses hay que
cerrarlos para siempre en esa zona y
hasta que haya una nueva decisión no se
explotará de cobre en esta zona de chile
hasta aquí las noticias sigan conectados
[Música]